hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar CDC evaluation of a
2-0 Lyme disease dia testing method and
potential diagnostic significance I am
Judy O'Rourke of let roots and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website the provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by bu mariya a world
leader in the field of in vitro
diagnostics for more than 50 years bu
mariya is present in more than 150
countries through 42 subsidiaries and a
large network of distributors you marry
who provides the diagnostic solutions
reagents instruments and software which
determine a source of disease and
contamination to improve patient health
and ensure consumer safety its products
from mainly used for diagnosing
infectious diseases to learn more visit
www.samhsa.gov/dtac asian window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left we now
present today's speaker lina Prisco PhD
dr.
ursula weiner Prisco has a PhD in
pharmacology as a laboratory and
clinical researcher and as a former
laboratory director at Martha's Vineyard
hospital dr. Priska serves as a clinical
researcher and consultant for many
health-related in laboratory
organizations including game area
incorporated quad Elle and Medscape dr.
Prisco will now begin her presentation
good afternoon good morning and thank
you for joining me I'd like to spend
today talking to you about two-tier line
testing and incorporating the current
CVC manuscript that was written recently
regarding this test as Judy said the
second slide actually shows a little bit
more about me I was an early adopter of
this Vitus line to dissociated assay and
I have run thousands of specimens using
the assay I will show you data that I
presented in 2015
using this assay and a validation
protocol and I am currently on the Dukes
County Health Commission so if you'll
forgive me for those of you who are
familiar more familiar than others with
Lyme disease I thought I'd ground us for
a few slides in Lyme and ticks in
particular so if you look here on the
left of your screen that is the
black-footed tick exodia scapularis at
the bottom in the middle is a tick that
is engorged and unengaged and you'll
notice the dramatic size of when a tick
has been feeding this particular tick
for those who are wondering was engorged
and was feeding for we estimated when we
took the picture about 36 hours up in
the right hand corner is a hematoxylin
stain of the Spirit key taken from the
spinal fluid of an infected patient so
one of the things that actually makes
this disease transmission difficult is
that the size actually matters now there
are lots of different ticks and you'll
notice on the left you'll see the size
differential between an adult male
female and nymph and a larvae and then
there's the Lone Star tick and at the
bottom the dog ticks so most
of us are familiar with the larger dog
tick and those of us who have dogs cats
etc we routinely pull these off our
animals however in the case of Lyme size
really does matter if you look at the
picture on the right you'll see how
small that nymph stage really is of this
tick and this nymph stage is the most
infected form of the transmission of the
disease and because of its small size
it's not always easily detected even you
know unclear visible on clear skin and
it likes to congregate in certain areas
where you may not detect it at all that
is in hair lines in socks legs pants etc
so it makes it particularly difficult to
know that it's there so one of the other
things that's important is to realize
that the life cycle is a two-year life
cycle for these ticks so it actually
begins if you start on the left in the
spring the larva the female tick drops
off its dear host and lays the eggs on
the ground and the larvae begins to
develop most of the transmission
actually starts through the white-footed
Mouse the larva feeds on small animals
where it's picked up and the mouse then
transmits it through the brush etc we
end up in the fall winter where the
larva becomes dormant and the following
spring the la remotes and then becomes
into turns into the nest which is the
most aggressive stage the nymph then is
usually along with the mouse and feeding
on the deer is transferred to another
host and that host often for people who
are walking in the woods etcetera
brushing up against leaves in their
yards etc it becomes a host and that's
when they become infected the nymphs
then grows to adult and we start all
over again
it's interesting to know in years where
the winters are mild and particularly
here where I'm located on Martha's
Vineyard adult ticks are not killed so
there is a greater production of food
for both the mouse and the deer and then
all that also produces a consequent rise
in the tick population because ticks are
not killed off as well so I put this in
here because I wanted to show a
progression of our ability and our
knowledge of detecting this disease so
if you look at the color I want you to
focus on the the darker colors where
those are the areas of are of high risk
and this was from the National Lyme Bank
predicted database in the year 2000 so
we're talking you know 17 years ago
where you can see in those dark areas
where that really was the areas that we
you know considered to be high risk
areas but I want you to look at the pink
area as well as as well and notice that
in the southeast and the west and the
Upper West and even in portions of the
Midwest that would consider to be a very
low risk of disease in 2000 if we then
look at CDC reported cases in 2001 you
start to see these dots where there
begins to be a bit of a spread where not
only do we see the same dark areas in
those same areas that we are aware of
but now we're starting to see cases in
Florida Texas a higher concentration in
Ohio Minnesota California and up in
Washington State
from there we move to 2015 and now you
can see the dramatic difference where
there is a much higher concentration in
the Northeast it appears to be spreading
south the concentration in the Midwest
is much heavier and there is now more
and more incident reports in
Florida California and in the northwest
so here shows a graph from the CDC line
database as of 2015 and what they call
confirmed versus probable cases now
probable cases are those that based on
serologic testing were equivocal so if
we looked at confirmed cases only those
are the darker bars and that really is
based on serology it's also important to
know that these numbers do not include
patients who present with symptoms and
may be treated without serologic testing
so these are only patients who were
reported positive by serologic testing
now there's been a lot of talk about why
there's a difference between reported in
actual cases and why the discrepancy and
recently I'm sure you've all heard that
there are reports now that the CDC does
actually estimate that the actual cases
may be in the range from the mid 200
thousands to close to 460 thousand and
more cases and there are several reasons
for that the actual confirmed patients
must have a bull's eye rash now for some
areas not everyone gets a bull's eye so
we're talking about you know at the most
reported 70% of patients with a rash I
can say here on the island where we have
a very high incidence of lyme disease
there's probably only about 35% of the
patients that we actually see in any
given some are who come in with the rash
so it's either they're coming in before
the rash develops or they never develop
one the other
issue is to be positive you have to be
positive in serology tests and many
cases are diagnosed as having Lyme
disease based on symptom ology alone and
a lot of clinicians will not then test
they just diagnose the patient's based
on symptoms with or without the presence
of a rash and treat them the third issue
is positive results are reported to
Public Health offices where the
patient's primary residence is located
so if you look to the right some of
these case numbers may be slightly off
as for example here on Martha's Vineyard
we have many people who come here to
visit who were probably bitten here by a
tick become infected with Lyme but
actually go home somewhere else where
they're diagnosed so our actual
incidents and prevalence numbers may be
incorrect
so I can imagine that you know may
happen in other places throughout the
world as well and finally most health
agents agencies we send paperwork to
physicians to fill out this report on
Lyme disease and I know for us one of
the cases and now that we have
electronic medical records etc
physicians are inundated with all kinds
of administrative tasks that they have
to do and the paperwork isn't often
filled out mainly because they also in
the physicians I have spoken to feel
that it's not a communicable disease so
they're less apt to fill out that
paperwork so when we talk about the tick
life cycle we also then can then map
that back to a distribution of infection
on months and months and that varies so
obviously you see a very low infection
rate when it's cold and there may be
snow on the ground etcetera and that
starts to peak when we are outside and
that's May June July
as September usually for most areas now
on the island we also see another bump
in October November and even sometimes
up into the first couple weeks of
December because we have a lot of
hunters hunters sit and tree stands and
they walk through the woods etc and at
that point they become less aware that
the ticks are still active etcetera so
we do get quite a few infections in
another bump that will actually equal
the levels we see in either May or
August at certain times of the year
later in the year so for those of you
who are not as familiar with the actual
symptoms I want to focus on the left
side of this slide where you know
looking at here is a number of cases
about to a little over 200,000 cases and
you can see that you know 71 percent of
the cases have the characteristic rash
30% are showing arthritis and then
Bell's palsy at 9 at the next most
frequent symptom and then you'll see
cardiac meningitis and radicular aqua c
of following along as I mentioned here
on the island we see less cases with the
rash and quite a few cases of what we
would call Lyme arthritis now if you
look at the right side of the screen the
general thought is is there are three
stages to this disease and they happen
in days and weeks to months to years
stage one being the rash happening in
days to weeks chills fever what we call
here the summer flu which really doesn't
exist it's most likely some tick-borne
disease with the highest probability
being Lyme disease moving to
stage 2 which is weeks to months where
people will report facial muscle and
other muscle weakness muscle aches joint
aches cardiac abnormalities and
sometimes palpitations and then stage 3
where you really get into that chronic
area where chronic symptoms persist of
muscle weakness parent asia's difficulty
with speech irregular muscle movements
and some neurologic symptoms so let's
take a look at what this rash actually
can look like so most people has been
called the bullseye and that's true and
that's the one that you would see at the
bottom in this representation however I
have seen patients with one bite and
rashes over their entire body I have
seen patients with very pinpoint rashes
and there are a small centimeter in size
depending on you know where they were
bitten etc some of them are uniformed
some of them blister some of them have
bruising patterns some of them are just
spread and spread they're not round at
all so there can be a variety of
presentation so to actually think that
they they're quite heterogeneous and
there can be numerous or single EMS so
in terms of treatment doxycycline still
remains the standard recommended
treatment initially clinicians would do
one week and then it bumped up to two
weeks now can be up to three weeks
sometimes it's one course sometimes it's
two courses depending on the symptoms
and the patient's complaints there is a
certain section of clinicians and
providers that provide patients who have
been what we call exposed
in that by I mean that they have been
fittin but they have no obvious symptoms
but you've pulled a tick off and the
patient's become quite nervous and there
was one publication that showed that
perhaps providing a dose of two pills
almost a loading dose for lack of a
better term with patients that this
would prevent to the development of the
disease and I'd like to strongly
advocate against that we see really no
clear evidence that this treatment
prevents the development disease at all
so as I said you may see treatment with
doxycycline for another two week course
if symptoms persist the majority of
cases are resolved after two week
treatment but there are those patients
who require another treatment for
patients who cannot take duck recycling
either because they are working outside
and they shouldn't have the sun exposure
or allergy etc cephalosporins are also
effective in this disease and
amoxicillin is used in children the
other thing that I'd like to stress is
that there is no evidence that long-term
treatment with antibiotics is effective
although there are several people who
are on IV treatment set cetera of
long-term antibiotics for chronic
symptoms there is no evidence that this
is effective so when we're testing for
Lyme disease what are we trying to
detect those of us who do this for a
living know that we're you know looking
at antibodies and these antibody
production and Lyme disease takes on two
stages you have your first stage in the
early stage where they are the much
larger antibodies the IgM Lyme
antibodies and then later on IgG
antibodies form it's thought the syrup
conversion from IgM to IgG and by
begins after about you know nine to ten
weeks you start to see at or months that
serve conversion take place but I would
caution to say that it doesn't always
happen I have seen patients here that
have had persistent IgM antibodies up to
you know at least two or three years
after infection so I wouldn't really use
this as a rule of thumb however that is
not you know the way we think of it we
think of seroconversion
and our current interpretation of
Western blots which I'll get to in a
minute actually uses that concept of
serial conversion to interpret positive
or negative 'ti but one of the things
I'd like to also emphasize is that from
patient to patient obviously because
we're talking about an immune response
there is a variability of antibody
production so that inherently also
affects our ability to detect these
antibodies and their presence from
patient to patient so I think we need to
keep that in mind these you know none of
this is you know written and gold
standard we know that these antibodies
exist but as in many immune diseases you
have antibody production that can vary
from patient to patient in terms of time
and amount so this is the standard
algorithm that is used and in the CDC
paper that we will be discussing this is
what they call the sttt or the standard
algorithm patients are screened for a
first presentation with the eliza the
EIA if it is positive or equivocal they
move to the Western block both an IgM
and IgG if it is negative you report it
as negatives and there's no further
testing required with this particular
specimen there is a note that if the
disease duration is short
you can then do it again after 14 to 21
days if clinical symptoms persist
efforts indicated at all clinically if
you look to the left side positive or
equivocal as I said I GM and IgG Western
bloc if the blot isn't term interpreted
as positive you report it as positive
now positive in this case is at least
five or more bands present per i GG + 2
or more bands for IgM if it is
interpreted as negative you report it as
negative and again it's a disease
duration is short you would redo it
after you do another screen so the
Western blot in and of itself is not
done in isolation it is confirmatory
testing of what you find in the EIA for
those of you who have never seen one and
again I apologize for those of you who
have this is a representative snapshot
of a IgG Lyme Western blot and if you
look to the far right of your screen
that is the positive control on the far
left is the negative control and Lanez 2
through 7 our patients and here's where
you can see the variability in response
lane 2 & 3 would be considered positive
4 5 6 & 7 because they have less than 5
bands would be interpreted as negative
for an IgG Western blot so this is
actually taken from the Mayo Clinic and
how they actually interpret and send out
in terms of their interpretation
guidance that is sent out on all their
Lyme Western blots reports and what I
want to emphasize here is that there are
often times you can have the presence of
Lyme antibodies and still be interpreted
as having not having the disease
and it actually happens quite a bit so
if you look at in the first boxes at the
top you have an IgM block that's
positive you have more than two bands
but your IgG plot is negative the
laboratory interpretation of this is a
couple of things it could be either
early disease as less than four weeks in
other words they are positive for IgM
they have not zero converted yet or it
could be a past treated and flecked
infection so in other words they've been
treated in the past based on an IgM
response so they never Sarah converted
however in a lot of clinicians eyes this
would be negative and I'll get to that
in a minute and the second line you see
an IgM block that is negative less than
two bands you see an IgG block that is
positive this is considered to be a past
treated infection or the person has zero
converted and again clinically this
would also often be considered negative
by many clinicians and I'll again I'll
explain in a minute then we have the
standard of what is in the CDC algorithm
- positive IgM bands at least five
positive IgG bands and that is
considered clinically positive with some
serum conversion taking place and the
last case is less than two bands an IgM
less than five bands and IgG if there
are no fans that are negative and if
there are just a few bands is considered
they may have had some exposure or
pasture or it be a past treated
infection and that is considered
clinically negative now let me just make
mention a little bit about these the
clinical interpretation what often
happens with most clinicians is they
look at the blocks as a total report
they are not looking at the results of
the IgM bla and they don't look at the
IgG bla as separate results so therefore
unless
they see a positive positive in both
areas of that IgG blop response many
clinicians who are not familiar with the
disease will then say that that person
is not infected with Lyme so I want to
just bring your attention a little bit
too as I mentioned the validation study
that I was involved with and 2014 and
into 2015 what we did here was we looked
at our banked clinical samples and ran
an analysis of these samples in the
total Vitus Lyme assay versus the
dissociated assay looking at
correlations and the difference between
the number of Western blots that would
be required and what we found was
interesting so if we ran the light total
in other words the non dissociated a say
anything that was positive you had to
run through a Western block in other
words Western blot was required although
76 of them actually ended up being
Western block required and positive so
you had a percent results that were
confirmed by Western blot of about 42%
when you've rant when we ran the
dissociated assay and only ran those
specimens in each block based on their
positivity or negativity in each of the
assays in other words if the Lyme m was
positive we ran the Lyme M Western block
if the IgG portion was negative we did
not run the IgG and the same for the IgG
dissociated assay so if the IgG was it
was positive we ran it in the Western
blot for IgG and not
I should also note that all equivocal
were considered positive so those were
run on the IgM side as well and despite
and using that paradigm you can see that
there was a significant difference in
the amount of Western blots that were
needed to be run and that the percent of
results that were confirmed by Western
blot was significantly different so what
we actually showed in this assay was
that we saw about a 23% reduction in the
number of Western blots that were needed
to definitively determine the aligned
diagnosis when you looked at the two
different assays as opposed to being our
total versus the dissociated assay
so let's now move to this current CDC
assay and what was done here was
actually in an excellent work and I like
to give anyone who's on the phone that
may be from the CDC a shout out it was
very very thorough very excellent work
and briefly let me just describe what
they did so I feel Mary you recently
launched its associated first year test
and that was available to everyone I
believe as of January this year the
dissociated Vitus assay your uses of
purified recombinant test antigens but
what's important here is the IgG part of
the assay also includes the variant
region in variant region of the sea of
ir6 which we would commonly call the c6
by testing the IgM and IgG antibodies
separately as the first tier it provides
an opportunity for those of us who use
the assay for a different diagnostic
testing algorithm than what you see with
the standard testing and I'll go through
some of that in a minute and tell you
why
the rationale and how what they did for
methods was they used 471 Bank serum
samples that they had from Lyme patients
they used previously collected and
published data on study samples from a
variety of sources including for the
Western blots for Indian etics in terms
of IgG and IgM Western blotting and they
use the c6 assay also from very straight
so the two-tiered test interpretation
was performed according to record
recommended CDC guidelines and as
previously reported for all samples so
that means that in order to be called
positive on the Western blot you had to
be meet both levels of that criteria
IgM and IgG and apologises this is a
little blurry this is actually taken
directly and dropped in from the paper
but the upshot is is that there was a
great correlation between the total
assay and the dissociated assay
so the sensitivities and specificities
were both very similar one of the things
that they did look at that clinically we
don't always pay attention to but in
research we often do is other potential
comorbidities and compounding factors
when we're testing for Lyme disease and
you'll see some of those cases here
where they looked at specimens with
other diseases etc that are sometimes
known to cross-react in these assays and
you should note that the total assay had
a higher cross reactivity with other
diseases than the dissociated assay but
as I mentioned you can also you know
leave that up to
clinicians may screen for these at the
same time but since the sensitivity was
specificity was so high most clinicians
are fine with not also testing for these
unless they get back a line negative
result so here in this particular table
you can see the results that they got
with a variety of two-tiered testing so
what they did here was what they call
standard testing where you see the total
assay to the far left the dissociated
assay the next column and then the c6 a
say as the confirmatory tests in the
third column the fourth column is the c6
si and the modified testing following
the Associated assay and the last column
on the right and what this shows you is
that the sensitivities and specificities
when the two different strategies were
followed were actually pretty similar
there was a 76% sensitivity for the c6
out what we'll call the modified c6
algorithm with the total lime assay and
a 77% sensitivity with the dissociated
assay using the c6 as the follow-up
assay however there were significantly
higher sensitivities obtained when
immunoblot were used as the second tier
test so the modified algorithm approach
in this case resulted in sickness and
higher sensitivities compared to the
standard testing algorithm so what this
is really saying is is that you know
Western bla although this is what we
routinely use may lack some sensitivity
in terms of our follow-up testing and
that's probably best
shown by this it's a little more less
complicated than what you just saw so if
you look in total across the study what
the upshot is is it reduce the number of
Western blots required so if on the
right you look at the total assay for
all of those four hundred and
seventy-one that were P IAS that were
initially performed 159 of them were
positive or equivocal and in that assay
you don't know if that's i GM specific
or IgG specific you just know that you
have a positive assay that required 159
IgM immuno blocks and 159 i GG immune
applause now these numbers and
parentheses refer to the numbers of
immunoblot that were required if you
used a 30-day duration of disease cutoff
CDC guidance recommends that anyone who
is thought to be infected longer than 30
days that you not run an IgM immunoblot
as those results are suspect
however clinically I think we can all
agree that that rarely happens you get a
positive on that lime screen the the
Eliza you run both immuno blocks you
really don't pay much attention to the
duration of disease you run them both
nonetheless out of the original 471 at
the bottom you can see had to run a
total of 318 Western blots in the middle
there were 942 EEI a's perform now
remember that's 471 i GM Eliza's and 471
idgi a's so initially you're running
double what you would normally run
because you're running but them both
separately when you get the results from
those from there there were 103
one lime he is that were positive or
equivocal and 101 lime IgG e is our
positive break it down further when that
was run as a confirmatory test for
immunoblot 131 of them were positive on
IgM and 101 were positive on IgG so 232
of those immunoblot were positives which
is less than what we saw in the first
essay protocol if you follow up the
modified testing protocol and use the c6
as your testing you'll see 471 c6 e IAS
were performed that asterisk I wanted to
call your attention to is that this
would exclude IgM testing because as if
you remember I said the invariant region
of the ir6 portion on the antibody is c6
and it is on IgG it is not on IgM so
therefore you're really only looking at
i GG responses here from the original
471 112 of the c6 e IAS or positive or
equivocal of those 112 IgM immuno blocks
were run 112 IgG immuno blocks were run
and you came up with 224 total
immunoblot now one of the things that's
interesting no matter which protocol you
went through whether it was the
dissociated ice assay or the c6 assay
you still ended up with fewer immunoblot
than you do
if you ran the total assay so the
overall findings that confirm that there
is a reduction of at least 23% in the
number of immunoblot needed when you run
the dissociated assay as the first tier
yeah and that's pretty much very close
and almost exactly the same number of
reduction that we saw in the 147 that we
ran the number of false positives using
the Vitis dissociated assay was reduced
by 50% compared to the total assay and
when either the total assay where the
dissociated assay were followed by a c6
e IA in a modified approach increases in
specificity were observed and finally
they mention that all modified
combinations of testing were more
sensitive than the standard algorithms
now whether or not we end up moving to a
c6 approach I think by looking at those
numbers you can really see some of the
benefits of running a dissociated assay
compared to a total assay I mean not
only do they only corroborate the
previous studies that I showed you it
significantly does reduce the western
blots needed for confirmatory testing
mainly because you only have to run the
blot that is positive from the either
the igme ia or the IgG IgE a in our case
and what we see in our clinic is that
you get first line results of the
specific Lyme antibodies that are
present inspected patients it allows you
a quicker snapshot and window into where
that patient is in their disease course
so in other words if you have a patient
who comes in who is i GM positive only
you can pretty much assume that they are
in the early stages of the disease they
may not have serious symptoms at that
point however they have not zero
converted at that time unfortunate
the in order to confirm a lot of this
I'd have to say you know Sarah logically
it is very very difficult to get a
patient to come back in for
convalescence testing however I can say
in those patients that I have convinced
to return in research purposes we do
find that born out that once they were
treated they did cero convert later on
however that is where we also see the
persistence of those IgM antibodies for
much longer than what you might
clinically think they would be so I'd
like to say in closing and I'd be you
know willing to take any questions in a
few minutes that this dissociated as
they actually provides your laboratory
with quicker diagnostic results that you
can couple with clinical symptoms that
may or not be present giving you a
window into the disease course and
potentially leading to an earlier
diagnosis and treatment of Lyme disease
we all have heard the horror stories and
know the issues for those patients who
have in the past been told that their
serology was negative and therefore they
did not have Lyme disease and then went
on to develop full-blown chronic
symptoms and how they linger and that
population unfortunately is growing and
I think anything that we can do to
actually increase the earlier diagnosis
and this particular disease and treat it
quicker would be clinically useful I'd
like to thank you for listening and Judi
I'll turn it back over to you for
questions
thank you dr. Christopher for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the proving
and window dr. Priscilla answer as many
questions as time permits the first
question is how much of a cost reduction
have you seen in your labs using Vitus
associated athing so I would say because
the Western blot is so much more
expensive than these Vitus dissociated
acid and began you can narrow down the
amount you are running my last
calculation was that we actually saved
about 30% and costs and on this lime
assay alone just in reagents now that
doesn't mean that does not include
manpower etc the other thing that's
important is remember you're also
reducing costs to patients as well how
long have you mean have you been using
c6 confirmatory testing in your lab and
have you seen similar results to the CDC
study I have used in the research
setting and upon request
c6 confirmatory testing and I've been
doing that now for about 18 months and I
do see very similar results as the CDC
has shown it's pretty remarkable and
like I said I'd like to you know really
emphasize that you do not see the same
type of reaction in patients who are not
i GG positive so just keep that in mind
have you ever used the c6 peptide assay
and seeing the same results yes how much
of a reduction in a Western blot have
you seen using the Vitis dissociated
athing
we see at least on our end at least a 20
to 25 percent reduction and Western
blots that are needed and interestingly
it also depends on the
patient population we get into the
clinic as I mentioned because we're an
island we also see a lot of tourists so
sometimes some seasons we get a lot of
people early in the disease and you see
fewer reductions but on average that's
at least 25% reduction that happens in
the event the patient insists online
testing and the EIA screen is negative
and the Western blot is positive for IgM
antibody so how would so I guess the
question is how would you have an e I a
that's negative and a Western blot whoa
all right so you're saying you would
have a Western blot that has less than 1
or 2 bands so that it would come back as
some type of exposure I have seen that
in the past and generally what I do is I
revert back to symptoms and if the
patient is you know telling us that they
clearly have symptoms they would be
treated and you know a lot of times
those symptoms are very subjective
muscle aches etc and I think in the case
of Lyme it is always much more important
to err on the side of caution and in our
case here our clinicians would more than
likely treat that patient rather than
have them to go on and develop chronic
symptoms can you clarify the
significance of the c6 region of the IgG
yes so what you're looking at in the
seasick region whether or not you want
to consider it significant is it's just
another target so there's an invariant
region on the IgG antibody that is
present that you can also that you can
also target and it it actually confers a
little bit more sensitivity in
terms of the detecting the IgG antibody
and it is essentially another way to
look at the presence of IgG antibodies
when is the reason for this he fixed
assay only looking for IgG and is there
any evidence that IgM antibodies don't
react with c6 well actually there is
some cross reactivity that I have seen
personally but not having used it in a
volume that I would be comfortable
saying that there is no reactivity I
would say you could probably expect that
these tests also indicate current
sections like anaplasmosis actually no
they do not because these are lines
specific antibodies there is some
crossover there are some inflammatory
mediator antibodies that are produced
but they're produced in a low enough
level that these are live specific
antibodies however I would caution most
clinicians and have many times where
even here on the island we see at least
a 5 or 6% ko infection rate with other
tick-borne diseases so even if you've
ruled out Lyme it would be you know also
good to make sure that people are not
co-infected with other tick-borne
disease where would line PCR fit into
the algorithm at this point PCR is not
useful in anything but cerebral spinal
fluid the actual spear key DNA is not
doesn't appear to be present and high
enough and plasma to be used in a plasma
level so it's really only used in the
CSF at this time speaking personally
again I have tried using a very nutrient
Media to immediately inoculate cultures
to try to grow this mierqi and I have to
say the actual success rate of growing
it is pretty abysmal it's pretty tough
to do the c6 invariant is present only
on IgG why is the immunoblot IgM run on
the c6 assay that's a good question
I actually the only thing and I think
you know we may have to ask the our CDC
colleagues but I think the idea was to
put the specimens through the same type
of paradigm that they would have seen
normally so you're going to run it run
it through both but the specificity
really leans much more heavier on the
IgG side than it does on the IgM side
please elaborate on the identity of the
multiple bans on Western blot I'm
assuming by identity you're talking
about the markers so on the Western blot
there are several different types of
antigens so when you look at the bands
there are a collection of a known 9 or
10 I believe that are known to be
present in Lyme disease and that's what
you're seeing as markers on the side
there so the 17 kilo Dalton of those are
actually protein markers for antibodies
and what you see is the presence or
absence of those particular bands on the
Western blot some of these you see in
IBM as well but and some of them appear
at different stages of the disease I've
sometimes seen that as true and
sometimes is not however what you see on
the right side of that particular slide
are the animal antigens that are
proteins that are normally screened for
in an IgG Western blot
if the Irie some of my Gran's rash is
only 71 percent at best why does the CDC
consider that a requirement for
confirmed positive and the person says I
know you can't sleep there the CDC but
can you give an Indian on this right all
right so let me just say that that
originally was the symptom that was used
as a diagnostic marker for Lyme and I
think it's you know we're now seeing it
more and more and enough prevalence and
incidence and realizing that that may be
a bit artificial but because that has
been used as a diagnostic criteria that
actually still exists however most
clinicians will look for the rash but if
they don't see it that does not mean
similar to that if they don't always get
a positive serology will they say that
this person has does not have Lyme
disease so I think you know people are
getting better at saying okay they don't
have a rash but I'm going to test them
anyway do the antibodies persist after
treatment actually they do they can
persist sometimes years after treatment
I have patients who come in to the
clinic on the research side who I was
working with who have had infections up
to six seven years ago
and still have both IgM and IgG
antibodies perhaps not to the level that
would be considered positive on the
Western block in other words two and
five but they do definitely persist
which is why it's really important to
get a very detailed clinical history
from these patients well often do you
see persistence of IgM for prolonged
periods of time Sayed many years as I
just said I would say I've seen the
persistence
and probably I'm trying to think of our
data bank probably and about I want to
say and I'm just you know thinking off
the top of my head here don't quote me
on is probably about twenty percent of
the patients that we have in our data
bank have persistent IgM antibodies for
longer than a year what is the
prevalence of Lyme disease in the kick
population that's an excellent question
we recently just did a survey of both
the deer and tick population to see
basically how many deer we had in a
particular square area because they were
easily too easier to detect in the
white-footed Mouse and then an estimate
of certain areas of where we know the
ticks are quite prevalent and here on
the island we see at least 50% of the
ticks here on the island carry Lyme
disease and another 30% of those will
carry more than one tick borne disease
so I think it's safe to assume that if
you have a tick on you I'm here on
island I would assume it's carrying line
and to seek assistance immediately with
the Vitis associated asset or both
results reported to the physician and if
so is that problematic for their
interpretation actually it's not and I
do report both and they are both
reported we have done a lot of education
around this assay here to physicians to
train them to look at both what they
were getting before and what they're
getting now so they really do have a
better understanding of what they're
seeing so it hasn't been a problem for
us mainly because we you know we did a
lot of education around it so that they
understand what they're looking
and then they also realize that they may
only get one and maybe not to block
results back but they are quite
comfortable with the dual result and
really like the ability to know which of
the two antibodies they have present or
both what is value of the line pcr and
how does it compare with the EIA well
aligned PCR has very limited use as I
was talking about it's really only used
in cerebral spinal fluid in some joint
fluids is really the and so it has a
very very limited use the EIA obviously
is that you know is much more well used
and off the available first tier screen
so unless you're you know got someone
who's you know has a hugely engorged
joint or is complaining of a headache
and nothing else
the live PCR really doesn't have much
use compared to other tick-borne disease
PCRs where you're actually whether that
be anaplasmosis or bebido SACEUR say or
in terms of those PCRs which are quite
predictive you test CSF for Lyme and if
yes what method you use we don't do it
here on the island we do send that off
to the Mayo Clinic and I believe they
use the wrong PCR developed method so I
really can't speak to that you said you
had a 30% savings of cost of reagents
even with buying twice as many screening
kits
no so cost of reagents in terms of if
you're thinking of it in terms of
because you have to run one of each the
actual screening kit cost is
not double and when I said I had 30% of
savings I was talking about also that
you did not have to run as many Western
blots so that was included in our
savings estimate clarify we used the
dissociated Vitus IgG and IgM and have
been sending positives to our reference
web for full Western blot as opposed to
just i GG Western blot or IgM Western
blot okay we can't do more of the
question so if just CIA IgG is positive
we could send only for IgG Western blot
correct wait if you're any everybody
good no no please please continue I was
just going to say by you know standard
and guidance you only run blots on those
AIAS that are positive so if you don't
have a Western blot that's or a EIA and
IgM say that's positive you don't need
to run the block is there any evidence
of the penetration of non-us strain um
actually that's a good question and I
think where we're actually seeing that
is in some other what they're calling
other tick-borne diseases through the
Lone Star tick that is now carrying a
Lyme like disease it is very similar
however its trajectory in terms of
infection is quicker and a little more
variance and it doesn't appear as if and
what we see in that particular disease
is an IgG and C 6 reactivity and less of
an IgM reactivity so there's some
question of whether or not that's
actually even a Lyme variant or not but
that's all that I'm aware of
in terms of spread throughout other
regions and areas of the u.s. from you
know over the past 20 years is a lot of
things that people are traveling more
number one their pets are traveling more
etc and there is more of a tendency for
people to be you know outside hiking etc
and they may not be aware of ticks and
tick borne disease you believe the
warmer weather will cause a large number
of cases to spread to other states with
presently low numbers and see an overall
rise in all states this year that would
be significant enough for the media
outlets to report it to the public
that's a good question too I know we see
a rise here we're already seeing more
cases now in May then we did last year
mainly because we had a pretty mild
winter now whether or not that
translates to other places that had a
mild winter I can't say but I imagine if
we're seeing it they probably are - hey
looks like we may have time for one more
question
um this person says from they had
technical difficulties oh so they join
us a little bit late but they're asking
which island are you referring to you
Martha's Vineyard okay thank you and the
coast on HBC okay we can wait for more
questions to come in but during that
time I would like to once again thank
dr. Crisco for her presentation do you
have any final comments um I would just
actually like to thank everyone for
attending and if you have any questions
or whatever if I can be of any help be
Maru has my contact information etc you
can feel free to reach out to them and
I'd be more than happy to help you I
also like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by this
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration we
would also like to thank our sponsor
being marry you for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through November 8 2017
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye